if I were really to guess I would say
Rhonda Santos probably has a better
chance of beating Joe Biden because
I don't think the left will be able to
kind of gent the same hatred for Ron
DeSantis in the short amount of time as
they did for Donald Trump that to me
feels like lightning in a bottle that
kind of trump derangement syndrome is
going to be hard to duplicate with
somebody else and it's going to be hard
for the media to tell people oh this
guy's actually worse than Donald Trump
you thought Trump was bad we told you
Trump was a dictator but this new guy
who seems to be a family man and he's
pretty low-key and he doesn't go on
Twitter a lot he's actually worse than
Trump I just think there's a lot of
people in the center who aren't going to
buy that and so I think that the
combination of that and the fact that
DeSantis is a lot younger he could
really showcase that on the debate stage
against Joe Biden I think that's that's
a win in his calm